good morning kick it's Tuesday working
with Partners in Health our community is
now on Pace to raise over 35 million
dollars in the first five years of our
project to help PIH radically reduce
maternal mortality in Sierra Leone this
video comes in four parts what happened
what's happening why it's happening and
what's next so three years ago our
community began working with Partners in
Health to support their efforts to
strengthen the Health Care system in
Sierra Leone's Kono District which is
the epicenter of the global maternal
mortality crisis like in 2019 one in 17
women in Sierra Leone could expect to
die in pregnancy or childbirth so to
address this crisis PIH and the Sierra
leonean Ministry of Health wanted to
build a world-class maternal and infant
care wing of koidu government hospital
called the maternal Center of Excellence
the mcoe would not only have a blood
bank and surgical Suites to make
emergency C-sections safe but would also
serve as a teaching hospital to train
the next generation of Sierra leonean
nurses midwives and doctors so in 2019
we committed to help PIH raise 25
million dollars over five years so they
could break ground on this Hospital
expansion we weren't sure how we were
going to raise the money but never
underestimate nerdfighteria so where we
now will despite supply chain challenges
the maternal Center of Excellence has
begun construction although it is a long
way from finished but we don't need to
wait for a building to start to see the
change Kauai government hospital is
already becoming a teaching Hospital the
first cohort of nurses and midwives
recently finished their rotations there
and this is really exciting because it
means more people in the region can
pursue those careers also because we
have blown past our initial goal we've
been able to expand this project to
extend our support to several Primary
Health Care Clinics in the region
including one in the town of kaima and
kaimu is the scene of a really important
story this year I think which is that
there was a huge outbreak of a diarrheal
illness in town and that's one of the
leading causes of death for kids under
the age of five and in response the
clinic treated people who got sick but
also recognized is that there was an
underlying cause to this outbreak which
is that neither the clinic nor the
community had regular access to clean
water and so the PIH team drilled a well
that now provides clean water not just
to the clinic but also to the town I
think this is part of what makes PIH so
special they respond to acute Health
crises but also to The Chronic
underlying causes of those crises and
this approach is working in Kono child
mortality at the hospital has fallen by
over half just in the last two years
unsexy but critical system stuff like
efficient warehousing and
climate-controlled storage of medication
has improved the availability of
everything from medicines to surgical
gloves and maternal mortality is
declining as well even though it is
still hundreds of times too high I think
it's really important to note that this
is not happening because progress is
like inevitable if we've learned
anything from the last two and a half
years it's that progress is never
inevitable this is happening because of
the extraordinary commitment of Sierra
Leone's health care workers and because
of your support like thousands of people
donate monthly to this project at
pih.org Hank and John thousands more
have made one-time gifts and around a
hundred Nerdfighters have come together
to donate between two thousand and a
hundred thousand dollars a year to
ensure that every one of those dollars
gets matched you can get a full
Financial breakdown of where we are at
the unlisted video in the doobly-doo
should I call it the video info if I'm
wearing a suit probably so the video
info below but the other really
important source of revenue for this
project is socks and coffee oh which
reminds me starting today we have a
light roast available from the awesome
coffee club and it's great amazing
coffee sent to your house and 100 of the
profits go to charity we named our
roasts after butterflies that live in
Sierra Leone like our classic medium
dark roast is called Octavia after
presses Octavia a butterfly that changes
color depending on when it's born and
our brand new light roast is called
calypso after this this ethereal Beauty
balenoir Calypso so now whether you're a
fancy coffee person who likes light
roasts or a regular coffee person we've
got you covered awesomecoffeeclub.com
all that said by far the most efficient
way to donate to this project is pih.org
Hank and John it's just that if you're
gonna get socks and coffee anyway and
you are why not do it for charity so
what's next well for me at least this is
the biggest news PIH has a long history
of fighting for justice and equity in
healthcare when the global Health
Community said it was impossible to
treat multi-drug resistant tuberculosis
in poor communities PIH proved otherwise
they also helped lead the charge to
expand access to antiretroviral therapy
for people living with HIV and our
biggest hope when we started this
project is that even though our work
would be focused in just one region of
just one country we could use that
example to prove that it is possible to
radically reduce maternal and child
mortality everywhere and then maybe the
progress in Kona would help Inspire
other partners to expand the work and
we're starting to see that PIH has now
working with Sierra Leone's Ministry of
Health and the World Bank to strengthen
the Health Care system in the kailun
district which is just south of Kono as
pih's John Lasher recently wrote me you
and your community which now feels very
much like our shared Community have
paved the way for more Partners to join
us and for us to expand our work and
there is so much left to do and there is
so much left to do like one of the big
challenges here is that as a Health Care
System gets stronger more people begin
to trust it and more people begin to use
it like in 2019 the Primary Health Care
Center in the town of sawafe Saw 4 700
visits and in 2020 it Saw 4 700 visits
so like from the outside one might
conclude that the clinic isn't very
important to the community or that it
doesn't serve a very large patient
population but because over 95 percent
of pah Sierra Leone's employees are
Sierra Leone and and live in the
communities where they work they
understood that something else was
happening which is that the clinic did
not have the staff space stuff and
systems to provide good care and in 2021
after PIH started supporting the
facility the clinic in suafe saw over 20
000 patients a 500 percent increase over
the year before and as the clinic
continues to get stronger it may see
even more patients so this is a really
critical time for our work with Partners
in Health because patient volume is
increasing so dramatically and we are
hoping that our support will increase
too needing an emergency C-section in
Kono continues to be a life-threatening
emergency but we know it can change we
know it can change because when we
started this project three years ago one
in 17 women in Sierra Leone could expect
to die in pregnancy or childbirth today
it's fewer than one in 20. that is still
much too high but that progress is real
we can choose to share a world where
maternal and child deaths are rare and
thanks to your attention and support I
really believe that our community is
helping to bring about such a world even
if you can't personally donate your
attention and advocacy helps draw
attention to the global maternal and
child mortality crises which brings in
big funding Partners if you can donate
the link is pih.org Hank and John
nerdfighteria I continue to be
astonished by you Hank I'll see you on
Friday